hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch a
video from our dear friend gene Jeter
these are easily our most viewed videos
on YouTube you guys yo check out his
channel has a wide variety of stuff
ranging from short films sketches
monologues try not to laugh challenges
even did one of us Tyrone Magnus as well
and now he has one from this channel
called gold juice I've never seen any of
gold juice videos I asked him is it best
if I watched some gold juice before we
do it try not to laugh and he said no so
maybe this will make us a subscriber to
gold you sorry for elbowing you I'll do
it intentionally next time anywho let's
get to it
try not to laugh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right did you did you not laugh did
you try not to do succeed and not each
friend concerned is what I went through
try not to wonder if this is a
relationship falling apart so are they
like a vlog channel that covers their
toxic domestically violent emotionally
abusive relationship that's what I got
from it and that's what I got from
admire jeans I for surrealist try not to
laughs I think I found the Tyrone one
funnier outright but I was equally
compelled by how strange and kind of
skittery this was well I was sneaking
about how they're fighting a lot in here
and in there getting along you can't
change the path and it just seemed like
whoa what is this channel about I don't
watch like couple vlogs or anything like
that I get uncomfortable watching those
especially when they like capture
themselves fighting and whatever that's
what I just got from they're like oh I
think not getting along
should I talk to them is that what he
wanted us to watch this because you want
me to give them some relationship advice
it's an intervention okay
advice tip number one don't put your
arguments on camera for the public
session
yep you you don't want to look out to a
sea of thousands to ask right things are
involved but hey if it's going well for
them it's go
well for them gene must be a big fan I
think those are the Tyrone ones probably
funnier because we know Tyrone we know
the channel whereas we don't know gold
juice I mean I got gold and I got juice
well you got both okay I see Otis yeah
just got the do don't watch it's me I do
drink my gold juice what does gold juice
I've not a clue that it's slang for
something named you know where I'm going
with this hey Siri what is gold juice
Siri knows you too okay so apparently
it's just a word for their YouTube
channel let's go check out the gold
juice YouTube channel they are
struggling yeah
1.9 million followers ooh boy it must be
hard being this couple right here no I
take it back put all your relationship
fights on YouTube cuz it seems like it's
going really well for you pregnant
girlfriend finds cond yeah not gonna lie
I read their latest upload and I was
like that sounds pretty intriguing
actually I might go check that out that
sounds like a lot of fun definitely I
definitely want to see what transpires
when she finds those condoms I hope that
she beats the [ __ ] out of him on camera
as well for free Oliver he wants to go
says she has been cheating on me I have
proof well these have to be clickbait
titles they have to be no I hope it's
authentic and real that makes for damn
good YouTube television right there
so wait it says that they have this baby
but they also did a baby prank is the
baby now that they are having a prank is
she wearing like a pregnancy suit are
they gonna he's actually there she's
actually a pregnancy find out we're
pregnant our baby is showing I kept
trying gender predictions and now
pregnant girlfriend finds condoms I want
to know this couple I want to know this
couple I want to have an orgy with this
couple dude if you're a fan of gold
juice get in that comment box and tell
them to come on the channel they're both
very good-looking
buta makes sense why they're successful
as they are yeah I mean that's the step
one is be beautiful it's usually a quick
ticket to success and I found that's why
this channel really started blowing up
mm-hmm
once we partnered up yeah that's right
all the handsome well Jean this was
disturbing and I am concerned for this
couple
I feel like financially they're gonna be
fine oh yeah they look like they're
doing very well in the youtubes but hey
they got a baby coming they better get
to that 2 million subscriber point
well when their baby is old enough to
watch YouTube videos so like 3 they can
just look to their role models not
through actual parenting but you're just
watching their parents and how they
interact on camera oh yeah they learned
so much about their family history the
way everybody should which is on YouTube
yeah for sure
yeah part of me wonders if they actually
do have nice times and Jean just didn't
bother to pick any of those for the try
not to laugh cuz it's not funny when
nice things happen
I think Jean should do a compilation of
you know domestic violence caught on
camera I think he can make that really
funny yeah and and really surreal and
avant-garde I mean you know to help
bring self awareness mm-hmm they're also
be really fine sure slapstick ah did you
know your did you know doing is a random
word I threw out there
domestic violence try not to laugh
slapstick it could be compilation of
slapping women women slapping men and
beating each other with sticks yeah yeah
yeah yeah I would be very literal and
you know exactly what you're getting
into when we have children John our arms
yeah yeah I'm hoping they watch this
video and that one we're recording yeah
this one were recording that way they
know what's funny and oh yeah what is
acceptable mm-hmm if you're committing
domestic violence it's only okay if
there's a camera record
it's that way it can be used for comedic
purposes and then eventually YouTube
will D monetize your channel but but not
for like a good year or two it's worth
it yeah yeah make that money while you
can I hope we have said all the right
things in this climate that we live in
uh-huh politically correct video mm-hmm
yeah I just won't make this I just gotta
clear up that we're joking this whole
video has been a joke but it's not a
joke these couples well weirder it is go
check out genes channel subscribe to
gold juice you know be cool they have
1.9 million followers let's click it and
see if it hits too and you have for the
last one
[Applause]
Wow guys subscribe we just got to create
72 thousand accounts and like and
subscribe through all those accounts and
then we'll gone assess their exact
number right well let's help them out
subscribe to gold juice subscribe a gene
Jeter I'll see you guys soon